there is a state trooper out there I
actually I wasn't able to get his name
there's a state trooper out there who
was filmed on video talking to some of
these protesters hopefully the peaceful
protesters and he was asked about
kneeling this is a black trooper and he
said look I'm here to protect your right
to do all this but I don't kneel for
these kind of political protests I only
kneel to God
and that's God only kneel for one person
and that's God I like it i like this
guy's attitude I like how he talks I
like what he's saying you might go a
little bit broader than that
okay because some you know I think
people kneel for other reasons than God
at least sometimes like for instance if
I were in the United Kingdom and I were
about to be made a knight you know I was
gonna be Sir Michael someday a boy can
dream
I would kneel down and you know I get
the sword on me you didn't kneel for
that you can kneel if you're Catholic or
Eastern Orthodox or Anglican you can
kneel and other sorts of Prayer you know
in contemplative prayer or people kneel
when they're meditating for instance
okay fine you could say more broadly
kneeling is a sign of respect right and
this is what's so weird about the
kneeling protests other than people
protesting their own country is that
kneeling has become a sign of disrespect
the left does this to everything they
invert everything and they've done it
even with the kneeling so now the
kneeling is a sign of disrespect where
does this come from I mean where do you
get this kind of situation where people
are actively protesting their own
country it has been building up on the
left for a long time in our most recent
actual left-wing president brought this
out in people his wife Michelle Obama
was just giving a graduation speech
unzoom for all of America and she she
explains this kind of left-wing activism
this kind of left-wing character which
is to stay angry she did she said be
angry don't let anyone ever tell you not
to be angry she begins by more or less
disrespecting and denying the reality of
the American dream but here's the thing
while this period is certainly
unprecedented it is not a complete
anomaly simply some random coincidence
to be dismissed now what's happening
right now is the direct result of
decades of unaddressed prejudice and
inequality the truth is when it comes to
all those tiny stories of hard work and
self-determination that we like to tell
ourselves about America well the reality
is a lot more calm
cater than that because for too many
people in this country no matter how
hard they work there are structural
barriers working against them that just
make the road longer and rockier and
sometimes it's almost impossible to move
upward at all because if you're required
to work during a pandemic but don't have
enough protective equipment or health
insurance from your employer or paid
sick leave well what is more essential
your work or your life there it is
there's the classic it's impossible you
can't succeed America's never gonna work
for some people it's interesting that in
this clip she went back to the pandemic
because it seems to me that so many
left-wing rioters peaceful rioters have
been ignoring the allegedly
extraordinarily deadly pandemic for the
past two or three weeks as they've
poured out by the hundred thousand to
protest right but that then at that
point they ignored the pandemic the
public health officials said it's
actually good to go protest don't worry
about the pandemic we'll worry about the
pandemic later so it's interesting that
you focused on that because it seems so
odd but it's also interesting that she
the wife of the first black president
who was elected twice talks about how
America's hopelessly racist hopelessly
unjust there's no way to succeed I mean
this is boilerplate left-wing stuff and
what they have to do is tell you as
Americans that you can't succeed this
place is hopelessly unjust you are
simply useless you can't you can't do
anything on your own because it
justifies more and more policies that
give them greater control over the
country that undermine our country's
political traditions and undermine your
very ability to pull yourself up that's
where she begins how does she foment the
kind of political action that she's
calling for she tells people to be angry
you who feel invisible please know that
your story matters your ideas matter
your experiences matter your vision for
what our world can and should be matters
so don't ever ever let anyone tell you
that you're too angry or that you should
keep
mouths shut uh here's my message to the
left in America you're too angry and you
should keep your mouth shut
that's my I know it's a different
message than Michelle Obama is giving
you but that is my message the left
pushes anger because when people get
really angry they don't think straight
because anger is an easy emotion it's
the it's the easiest emotion to play
it's the easiest emotion to live drew
Clavin says that anger is the devil's
cocaine anger is the devil's cocaine it
unleashes bad things in Italian culture
we have a specially Sicilian culture
here in America we have an expression
which is don't get mad get even
right the idea being when you're angry
you're not you're not going to be able
to control yourself as well you're not
able to think as well so get even calm
down that anger but the left encourages
that anger because that anger makes you
more easily to manipulate you can see
people running on the absurdity of this
anger all the way at some of the highest
levels in government
[Music]
[Music]